تحول الى البيت الابيض ومراسله الجزيره
وجد وقفي وجد هنالك تفاؤل في الرد الذي
قدمته حركه حماس مقابل رفض وكانه كلي
لتوسيع العمليه باتجاه رفح من خلال
التصريحات الامريكيه ما هي الايجابيات
التي تعتبرها الاداره الامريكيه في رد
حماس نعم بالطبع لم يوضح البيت ابيض حتى
الان الحيثيات الايجابيه في رد حماس ولكنه
اكد وجود اجزاء ايجابيه في رد حماس وايضا
وجود اجزاء ينبغي العمل عليها ولكن رغم
ذلك هناك تفاؤل لدى البيت الابيض وحقيقه
البيت الابيض متفائل اذا هذه المقترحات
واطار الاتفاق الموجود حاليا ويريد له ان
ينفذ واضح من تصريحات يربي بان لا تريد
هذه الاداره الامريكيه للعمليه العسكريه
الاسرائيليه الكبيره كما وصفها
الاسرائيليون ان تحدث هذه كلها التي
سمعناها قبل قليل بمثابه تحذيرات امريكيه
لحكومه نتنياهو من مغبه القيام بهذه
العمليه هو اكد بان الولايات المتحده لا
تدعم اي عمليه من هذا النوع كيربي قال ان
حمايه الاكثر من مليون مدني فلسطيني
الموجود في رفح والذين طلبت اسرائيل منهم
اصلا التوجه الى هناك حمايه كل هؤلاء هي
مسؤوليه اسرائيل سئل كيربي لماذا حتى الان
الرئيس بايدن لا يمارس ضغطه على نتنياهو
من اجل عدم القيام بهذه العمليه قال كيربي
بانه من خلال مباحثات وزير الخارجيه
بلينكن مع المسؤولين في اسرائيل لا توجد
اي مؤشرات الى احتمال قيام اس اسرائيل في
هذه العمليه بشكل وشيك اي في مستقبل قريب
ولكنه لم ينفي حقيقه احتمال حدوثها وهذا
امر يثير الكثير من المخاوف فدا بشان مصير
المدنيين الفلسطينيين الموجودين في رفح هل
يكفي التصريح بان حمايتهم مسؤوليه تقع على
عاتق الاسرائيليين ام ان هناك اوراق ضغط
اخرى يمكن لهذه الاداره ان تمارسها على
نتنياهو من اجل عدم القيام بها وان ينسى
او تنسى حكومه الحرب هذا المقترح اللهجه
المستخدم امريكيا في مقاربه رد حماس كيف
تبدو
وجد غزه حماس هم دائما يقولون الحرب على
هي ضد حماس وليست ضد غزه وقبل قليل حتى
سمعنا فدا عندما سئل جون كيربي عن
الامريكيين السته موجودين
في في غزه المحتجزين عن حما عن امنهم
وحمايتهم في حال بالفعل نفذت اسرائيل
عمليتها العسكريه الواسعه التي تقول انها
تعتزم تنفيذها قال ان حمايتهم وامنهم هو
مسؤوليه تقع على عاتق حماس ولكن حقيقه هو
تصريحه هذا يتناقض مع تصريح الذي كرره
اكثر من مره بان حمايه المدنيين
الفلسطينيين
الموجودين في غزه هي مسؤوليه تقع على عاتق
اسرائيل هناك تناقض واضح كيف يمكن لحماس
ان تحمي المحتجزين الامريكيين وفي نفس
الوقت يطلب من اسرائيل او يقال لها بشكل
واضح نحن لا ندعم عمليه عسكريه في رفح
ونحن ضد مثل هذه العمليه وعلى اسرائيل يتق
يقع عاتق حمايه هل تبدو المقاربه مختلفه
في الايام الاخيره لهذا الملف باختصار لو
سمحت
واج
حقيقه لا كل ما تريده الاداره الامريكيه
وتركز عليه هو اطلاق سراح جميع المحتجزين
هذا هدف منذ البدايه وضعته لا تريد
لاسرائيل ان تحتل اراضي من القطاع وهذا ما
يزال هدف قائم رغم كل العمليات العسكريه
لهدم في داخل قطاع غزه من اجل التجهيز
والاستعداد لاقامه ما تقول انها منطقه
امنيه عازله فداء الموقف الامريكي ما زال
في هذه المراقبه المقاربه على حاله وحقيقه
في هذه اللحظات وفي هذا الوقت الهم الاكبر
ربما للرئيس بايدن انجاز التعبير هو اطلاق
سراح المحتجزين وتحديدا الامريكيين اله شك
وجد وقفه مراسله الجزيره من البيت الابيض
شكرا لك